we're gonna talk about the news here
let's do it the first story we have for
everybody
national security adviser robert o'brien
trump should get
nobel peace prize for israel uae deal
this is from just the news john
solomon's outlives a senior white house
advisor jared kushner and national
security adviser robert o'brien
fielded questions in the wake of the
historic announcement
of an agreement normalizing diplomatic
relations between israel and the uae
now i don't i national security advisor
robert o'brien
sure i mean does do you know who that is
is his opinion
not real familiar with him all right
well i'll tell you what i'll tell you
whose opinion does matter
cat turd yes of course i i hopped over
to uh to twitter
nobel peace prize yeah if you look on
twitter they're actually talking
about it cat turd says president trump
deserves the nobel peace prize
you've got nick adams i'm not sure who a
lot of these people are to be honest
best-selling uh author endorsed by potus
many people cheering and it became
actually uh check this out
a trending topic on twitter nobel peace
prize people are calling for trump to
win the nobel peace prize after he
announced an agreement
to normalize diplomatic relations
between
israel and the uae it's cool stuff so
what does that mean what's going on do
you wanna
yeah so you want me to read through this
yeah do it to it yeah so
we have we're just talking about israel
and the united arab emirates
just finally normalizing relations and
the shift in the middle east politics
most important i think from this is the
west bank annexation and they're putting
it on hold so this isn't like
totally fixing everything to me this
seems a little bit like a band-aid
which may be an unfair characterization
honestly if they're calling for him to
get like a nobel peace prize
that's his fans i know i his fans are
saying give trump a peace prize i mean i
gotta be honest if obama got one for
whatever
he bombed people didn't he bomb american
citizens
he obama did kill an american citizen
that's true dude
abdulman al-awlaki oh actually a couple
of them yeah that that was
yeah that's why i'm uh i'm really
impressed by it yeah i think it's
fantastic
so well look basically
there there are a lot of people who act
like the emirates
and israel have are there they're
i'm trying to be careful here but people
have called them proxy states of the
united states
of the united states really yes israel
is a proxy state
yes that's what they're arguing and so
of of american imperialism or whatever
and this is this
what i've seen from the anti-war left
and to me i think
you've got an arabic nation now
recognizing the existence of israel
that's fantastic yeah and they're gonna
tourism direct flights
economics that's great dude i'm excited
like i never thought that i would see
this i didn't
think this would happen yeah i mean
we'll see if anything comes with it the
bigger concern is that
will it hold will there will there be
peace trump was asked about this
in uh a press conference and he
basically uh
he deferred i can't remember who he
deferred to but they were like we put
all our eggs in this basket
yeah and we have a deal so that's what
we're betting on
yeah foreign policy stuff it's so it's
so easy and unique it's so easy to talk
about isn't it you guys
foreign yeah it is really easy man we
got all the answers yeah
um this is these are some of the biggest
issues i care about when it comes to
electoral politics so you know in the
past
like i've mentioned before barack obama
they called him obama
right yeah he killed a lot of people and
when it came to
when it when it came to getting away
with it it was basically like if they're
of military age
in the middle east that was it yeah i
don't i don't like that
for obvious reasons because once you hit
a certain what you hit a certain age and
suddenly you're
cannon fodder whatever that's that's
awful that's unbelievable
yeah so so that wasn't new for obama
though was it
no i mean you mean like president-wise
yeah no they all did it well they all
thought that like a certain age meant
that you could just blow them up
yeah but i think it was actually that
they were killing civilians yeah and
they needed a way to justify
killing civilians that's not nice yeah
you know i i wonder about
what makes up the current trump base
you're like what who was it somebody
said that tulsi gabbard might speak at
the
yeah so i was watching because i was
really intrigued by this because
uh john kasich was speaking at the dnc
um and then tulsi gabbard was being like
considered to speak at the rnc and i was
like this is the greatest crossover of
all time i thought it was really funny i
was
i would say if we got away with tulsi
and they had john kasich we had
definitely won that round
but holy crap how weird whatever is
going on there's like i don't i don't
the i don't understand how you can have
so
look the the criticism i'm seeing of
trump from the left
is that this is not a real deal
right that he held off at the very last
minute for uh you know
a re-election bump and that these are
two states that already work for you
know work at the behest of the u.s so
it's no big deal
i disagree i disagree i think this is
this is major and this major
announcement means that
other nations and and people will start
to reflect on this and stuff
and now we have i guess tulsi gabbard i
don't know
i don't know if it's confirmed i don't
think it is okay i think i mean
yeah it'd be cool but she's a
progressive i mean if you look at her
record she is but she's consistently
been
about anti-war and it's resulted in her
for some reason being more aligned with
trump supporters
and that's the weirdest thing to me that
is weird i mean
but but but it's almost like we're
seeing the
a redefinition of both parties yeah yeah
the republicans
the the actual republican base today
feels so different from where the
republicans were even with mitt romney
yeah and i don't i don't understand like
has changed over the last like
five years i would say i feel like i
feel like everything has shifted because
from what i recall when i was growing up
i don't remember my family's attitude
attitude toward the idea of a war but it
was never considered like bad we were
not pacifists we did not think it was a
big deal we thought it was part of being
american
just kind of being involved overseas
which is obviously subject to debate
but then over time i started noticing
that the democrats
were only interested in being against
war when it helped their narrative and i
was like what's going on here why is no
one being consistent
when republicans started to be the ones
who were like no war is bad we got to
get out of there most of them not all of
them
your family is conservative yeah yeah
how do they feel about the war
with like during george w bush they were
kind of hands off about it
like they didn't think it was a good
thing but i get i think that we thought
that they had a really good goal being
over there especially after 9 11.
because following up with that they were
like this is something important that we
need to do we need to make sure this
doesn't happen again
yeah and it was bs but it really was the
new york times and the media and many
outlets who who told us that we were
facing these threats
and then when it came to barack obama
who was like i'm i i don't know
what was mccain's position was he four
he was so pro pro
yeah he was like bolton seriously right
right right that's why like
it's really funny when uh when mccain
died and i
you know with all due respect every
every everybody on twitter every
political spectrum
was just like not having it right like
they don't like the guy
yeah and there was a there was a meme as
a political compass and in the center
it was like an npc saying you know like
love and respect for
you know service and duty or something
right and then every faction the
authoritarian left the libertarian left
were like f mccain or whatever and it
was funny because like i was
i i didn't think it was like tepid or
centrist to to say
you know i can respect him you know he's
he died
i guess that makes me milk toast
centrist
see i don't really agree with that
either because i think that you can
totally make this statement that he
because he was partially his arms are
partially paralyzed because of what he
went through
overseas right that is a heroic act
like and and two things i think can
really be true at once especially in the
case of john mccain
he was extremely heroic he saved a bunch
of his men
but then he did not become someone who
loved peace
he continued to like the idea of war and
i did not i couldn't i couldn't square
that in my mind
you know you know what bothers me a lot
about like especially where
republicans used to be because this is
this is the point of what i'm trying to
get to everything's very different now
yeah like i for some reason you've got
there were there were more republicans
supporting trump withdrawing from
afghanistan
then there were democrats mind you there
were only eight there were so few
and there were three democrats yeah so i
mean look both parties suck
you know trump's trump something totally
different you know whether he gets a
peace prize or whatever
but with obama they were pro-war
to an insane degree all the liberals
just shut up yeah and that to me was
like that i was like you know what man
what what is this i i felt like
it was it was 2008 you know
yeah hope and change bring the troops
back and all these really great things
and it was not
not true and i think you know when you
look at the legacy of barack obama with
the national defense authorization act
with
bolstering you know our forces in the
middle east and all of the
the the uh extra digital extrajudicial
assassination of american citizens
you know it this is this this is rough
i know domestic policy is really
important but for me
where you know how i viewed the world
and
and how people viewed us and really
getting to
as close as we can to something we could
consider to be utopian
which would probably just be you know
carrying on in a
you know uh freedom capitalist system of
some sort with a mix like a mixed
economy some kind of social
safety net then i think you know worldly
affairs are really really important
and i'm thinking like how can we
actually function as a country
if we just routinely do these things and
how can we have a constitution
when you actually have a president who
straight up says if you're an american
but you're in a different country i can
i can drop a bomb on you right and
he talks about having a pen and a phone
and just bypassing all the stuff that
was put into place to make sure that
presidents didn't sit down with a pen
and a phone and do all this stuff
and like the kind of thing that
democrats are complaining about now with
trump
these things that are that the executive
branch shouldn't have control over
it's just grown too much they just keep
doing it obama i mean how did we enter
libya
like remember all that yeah obama yeah
yeah and it was like
you can't all the president can't just
do that and he just did it
and they were like well whatever well
and it's been that way non-stop
and so you know early on in trump's uh
several years ago he fired a bunch of
missiles into syria right all of a
sudden we saw these pundits like
truly a presidential candidate you know
or not candidate but truly so
presidential
no it's not strange they want they they
support the war machine
yeah and here's what here's what i think
is happening right now
it seems like someone accidentally
allowed real americans
to win an election yeah with donald
trump to put that it was an accident
there was like that pied piper email
from the dnc do you remember that one no
it was like donald trump is a pied piper
candidate that would
basically they wanted trump to be
prominent because it would make them
lose
wow and it made him win talk about how
stupid that was interesting yeah but but
i think about like
what it's really it's really become
obvious when you have a two-party system
and then you get a president who's
straight up like am over this let's pull
our troops out
and all of a sudden now you have the
never trumpers
the the republican establishment who ran
with with their tails between their legs
begging banging on the door of the
democratic establishment help us help us
you know and they're pro-war and they
and you and and then the democrats are
like
okay come on in and now they're
basically doing like war games and other
stupid you know whatever together
and they're all pro-war yeah and then
they run this media narrative that's
like
very obviously pro-war i read an article
from defense one
where they're like something really
weird is happening where for some reason
congress is stopping the president from
ending the use of force in a foreign
country never it doesn't happen that way
yeah but i think what we're seeing is
with trump and with
you know his efforts to withdraw forces
and now the middle eastern peace deal
these are bad for the
military-industrial complex these are
these are bad for these big companies
they want to go on big adventures they
want to be big machines and and you know
that that churn out economic value
donald trump talked about selling
weapons saudi arabia and all the stuff
and things that were people were very
critical about
and and now we see this happening and
now the trump supporters which
in it includes people who were liberal
before right what am i supposed to say
you know like donald trump has just uh
coordinated
this this this middle eastern peace deal
whether or not he's
deserving of all of the credit or some
of the credit or whatever
it's it's him it's him and i absolutely
think that uh israel and
and uh uae deserve lots of credit for
this absolutely
it's really hard to come to the table
and and there's a lot of uh
political issues involved and probably
historical hate
and trump they said he had he had a
vision he had a meeting
he brought him together at an event i
guess and he said i want to do this and
they both
were like we're interested in talking
and he helped make this happen
so what am i supposed to say to people i
i have friends of mine who are like
donate to biden you you have to trump
can't win and i'm like
middle eastern peace deal yeah dude what
am i supposed to
i've been talking to some people who
hate biden some prominent people some
high profile people who are like i can't
vote for trump man
and i'm like i hear you you know and
it's and and i'm
i'm pretty upset like i'm it's for me
it's begrudgingly
yeah i'm right now as of right now i
probably will and especially with kamala
harris
dude the the issue though too is like i
don't know how i feel about mike pence
but i'll tell you this if we get middle
eastern peace
if i mean that i can't i can't even put
in the words
the feeling like i have yeah because of
this i'm like
my jaw hit the floor and i see the
haters and i'm like
can you give him one day and they're
like it doesn't really mean anything i'm
like dude are you kidding me
you can't even if you can't even go to
these countries if you've ever been to
israel
and now we're starting to see a crack
break where it's like there can be peace
and it might not be perfect these things
things like this may have happened in
the past but
to this extent i'm stoked on it right
yeah
yeah but there's still people saying nah
this reminds me a little bit of the
north korea thing that they came up with
because i remember everybody i was like
this is another thing this is the first
time i started thinking you know i've
never
this is something i never thought i'd
see i thought we'd always be at war i
thought they would always be
threatening to bomb somebody in order to
get some kind of aid from us because my
parents told me that was how it was
that was what they did they would
threaten to do things and we would give
them help
and i was like that sounds like a really
wonderful situation
maybe we should do something about that
so when he when he kind of pulled that
off
or he made headway there i was really
impressed
and to me doing this is even more
impressive because it's not just
north korea it's not just one country
it's two different countries that have
been totally at odds
and then president trump who supposedly
has absolutely no standing in the world
kind of bringing them together and using
coronavirus
as a kind of right right that's one of
the things we're doing so it's that that
was amazing to me i was like
this is really smart this is very clever
diplomacy
yeah so one of the things they're doing
is they're going to be working together
on a coveted vaccine
and that it's great i mean this is all
this is all great
yeah when trump started talking with
north korea and
the the deal like to try and work
towards peace i think it's kind of
not really gone so well right north
korea kind of does their thing
and he got roasted for it and what
really bothered me is you know
donald trump walked in to north korea
with no security right i i was just uh
man once again i'm shocked i'm like
peace is possible
so here's my question for all the people
who are complaining about trump and all
the things he's bad at now like yeah
like
so so i saw somebody mention like you
know tim you say
you don't like trump's character who
should he act more alike and i'm like
it's a good it's a good point you know
people made fun of george w
bush but i'll be honest i think trump
has done a lot better
in the past couple of years relative to
where he was when he first got elected
and i can i can recognize that
right and i think it really comes down
to you know
finer points on issues related to social
liberalism
you know uh just like old old-school
wedge issues that still kind of exist
so you know what really bothers me about
trump and this is not really a
popular view i don't think because i
don't know how many people even think
about this anymore
but the budget really really bothers me
oh the yeah
national debt and i think that people
who are thinking about the future
are bothered by it and trump doesn't
seem to mind like i don't know how he
used to run his business
maybe this is why some of them went into
the ground but he doesn't just seem
interested in
there was only there was only there was
only a few of his businesses that were
bankruptcies
right he had hundreds yeah okay that's
fair yeah i know i i hear this all the
time and i'm like
bankruptcy doesn't mean you're a failure
it means you're strategically trying to
you know right but i i kind of thought
when he was elected that being a
businessman would help him
like pay really close attention to the
deficit no that's wrong
yeah there are a lot of benefits to a
business person
in government but i i think we see often
in the in the look man businesses are
authoritarian yeah totally
like you you start your own company you
can do whatever you want you hire who
you want you fire who you want
within the law there's still legal
issues here but you can snap your
fingers and be like you know we need
we need uh a giant a giant
vat of grape jelly yes and and your your
employee's going to be like uh
we're a sock company what do we need
just get me the jelly and you slam the
table and then go do it
yep yeah and so when trump you go into
government
trump sits in the room and he says
here's what we need to do and he ends up
with
i can't remember which one of his
advisors saying like
you can't do that yeah i think a few of
them have said that yeah and they're
like
it's the legal channels it's the it's
the red tape
and then he's like why you know then the
media comes after him they're like look
what he's doing he's doing illegal
things and it's like
and they mis-frame everything right of
course so now
it's really really it's gonna be really
really tough for them to drag him over
this
but uh earlier when i covered this when
it first broke like this is what i was
saying earlier
normally i'll have like i've got a bunch
of stories pulled up there are a bunch
of things i know i want to talk about
then this dropped and i was like wow
that's it yeah
and so i pulled it up on my i don't i
don't know and i wanted to be fair i got
some criticism
from other people to highlight but it
reminded me of
it was i think who was it nate silver
mm-hmm 538 when he tweeted
you won't even give the libs won't even
give trump one good
day and that was when he killed uh al
baghdadi
yeah the who was the leader of isis
austere religious scholar
as i recall yes this is this to me like
when i saw the note that came out uh the
statement that came out from the world
leaders
trump and uh netanyahu and i think it's
sheikh mohammed zayed
prince of uh uae and i saw these people
ragging on him
the craziest thing was the people who
are too dumb to understand what it was
and this this bums me out man you know
they don't they don't understand
when i it's i'm i don't get it i really
i just don't get it
how could i grow up hearing that war is
bad war is bad war is bad
you know from from the left from the
liberals
and now they don't care or they support
it
i've actually had a progressive friend
of mine say well you know
when it comes to war oh please i try to
be consistent and there are things that
i value
and my position on war has a lot to do
with the death penalty
right and the the the justification of
whether or not we should be doing the
things we're doing
right so you know what man if if this
leads trump to the nobel peace prize or
whatever
so be it man seriously yeah
yeah i don't know i think that's really
cool i think that's fantastic honestly i
think that this kind of work between
these two different countries and kind
of facilitating this
is fully deserving of a peace prize way
more i don't know what constitutes a
peace prize that's true maybe i should
look into that but because that would be
kind of interesting too right
you want to look up what obama got his
peace prize prize for yeah let me see
i'm gonna
i wanna do this listen i think i tried i
tried to to
to beat the dead horse when it comes to
issues of uh
foreign war middle eastern conflict all
of this stuff
and but but it really is like these are
my issues
that's why i really like tulsi gabbard
she's not
running and you know whatever that's why
it's i think it's really cool that she
might
speak i don't i don't know what the deal
is whether she'd speak at the rnc or
something
but i love it um i know that there are
other people that i also respect who
disagree i think dan crenshaw i think is
fantastic i tremendous respect
for the guy and i think he disagrees i
think he think uh he's he said we need a
presence over there
but this is this is it for me it's
something that i find uh really really
important
but we haven't we have another story
should you want to talk about obama real
quick yeah let me talk about him real
quick
let me go through this with you guys so
it says the 2009 nobel peace prize was
awarded to the u.s president barack
obama for his
extraordinary efforts to strengthen
international diplomacy and cooperation
between people
hey you know what trump just did today
he seriously strengthened
international diplomacy and cooperation
between these two
countries that were at odds i got i got
a question though yeah
uh didn't obama assume office in like
january
january 20 2009 2009 2008.
nine the election was in oh eight and
then in oh nine right he assumes
he's like immediate yeah they kind of
just gave him the award
literally so i'm wondering oh yeah you
wanna look at it there you go
what did he have to do to uh earn
no no here what the heck
so uh he said to the peace prize
december
he was uh they announced the award
october 9th
2009. whoa citing obama's promotion
of nuclear non-pro proliferation and a
new climate
in international relations fostered by
obama especially in reaching out to the
muslim world
the nobel committee's decision drew
mixed reactions from us commentators and
editorial writers across the political
spectrum as well as the rest of the
world interesting
look at this he accepted the award in on
december 10 2009
in a 36 minute speech he discussed the
tensions between
war and peace and the idea of a just war
saying
perhaps the most profound issue
surrounding my receipt of this prize
is the fact that i am the
commander-in-chief of the milit of the
military
of a nation in the midst of two wars
obama is the fourth president of the
united states
to have won the nobel peace prize after
teddy roosevelt would draw wilson jimmy
carter
and carter's honor happened after
leaving office wow
okay so uh after that obama added more
troops
and then sent a bunch of drones and
drones done blew people up yep
yeah yeah i do have to say it was
surprisingly self-aware of him to talk
about the country being in two different
wars at the time that he received this
prize
yeah thanks thanks for pointing that out
dude we noticed yeah and a lot of people
made the joke they're like maybe obama
should give the award back
once he started blowing up you know
military-aged men yep
there there are a couple people and i
i'm i'm not entirely sure so definitely
fact-check me i think obama killed four
people
that were american citizens without
charge or trial
and the scariest thing and and this is
credit to lukowski of
where change he was speaking to people
at
the um it was it was the i think it was
the debates right i don't know if you
know this
it was the debates and i think it was
the debates
they got some interviews and they asked
people
you know obama used a drone strike to
kill a 16 year old american citizen
without charge or trial
and the response was yeah well he should
have been he should have had a better
dad
okay yeah i think that i'm not sure who
said that
okay it's been a long time this was back
in like 2011 or 2012.
wow yeah and and where was the news
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live monday through
friday at 8 pm
if you want to catch the full show tune
in to this channel subscribe hit the
like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you